alors ensuite vous pourra compter aussi
alors essayé on va le dire c'est
vraiment beaucoup de gens retiennent
aussi ça du livre vous racontez votre
passage assez vite aux côtés de tir
agissions et vous parlez de moi dans le
livre en page 164 alors je sais pas si
c'est vrai ou pas mais je vais dire le
passage essayer ou par les tirs à 10 on
vous dit thierry ardisson kif à l'époque
de cyril hanouna une obsession temps ils
ne supportent ni son succès ni la place
qu'il occupe au sein de la chaîne rêvant
d'être à sa place
il passe son temps à le dézinguer à nous
parler de lui parfois avec beaucoup de
mépris
comme pour dire qu hanoune a fait du bas
de gamme là où lui ferait de la qualité
ils le détestent et ne s'en cache
absolument pas bah merci je prends ça
dans la gueule parce que vous raconter
l'épisode de la tarte à la crème avec
gibernau vers moi cet épisode et vous en
parler tu m'oublieras presque 10
hapsatou c'est quelque chose qu'on me
l'a jamais dit mine de rien se connaît
bien et on s'aime bien mais il ya
beaucoup de choses d'un livre que j'ai
jamais dit je sais mais c'est vrai que
voilà et vous me l'avez jamais dit moi
gt gt gt persuadé qu' il m'aimait
beaucoup alors je sais pas si c'est ou
si c'est lui mais regardant plus vous
l'avez ya pas longtemps au téléphone et
ça les lis plutôt bien oui bah alors on
va regarder l'extrait c'est par rapport
à cet extrait ou pierre ménès avait
parlé de raquel garrido qu'on aime
beaucoup mais vraiment on n'a rien
contre elle et il avait dit la veille
victime quiches et gilles verdez vous
étiez allé remettre une quiche et sur le
plateau exacte et fleurs thierry voilà
vous a mis la quiche dans la gueule
regarde c'est vrai et livreurs telle
erreur
à quel genre à tout dire
c'est un mais nous fait pas plaisir mais
on ne peut que l'équipe de touche pas à
mon poste en tant que livreur attitré je
vous offre une magnifique e tour tu es
un magnifique bouquet de fleurs oui ça
va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors donc on se rappelle tous de cet
extrait de ce passage alors c'est vrai
que vous dites donc tirer en réalité on
tarte et gilles verdez avec une violence
inouïe je les ai vus faire le tour de la
table
arrivé dans le dos jean et du maître
littéralement un coup de poing masquée
par la crème au départ j'ai eu peur car
j'ai cru qu'elle saigne et qui lui avait
cassé le nez j'étais à deux mètres de la
scène j'ai entendu un bruit sourd suivi
d'un tremblement de le des lèvres de
gilles est monté de larmes
thierry l'a humiliée et à jubiler il est
certain qu'il n'aurait jamais fait cela
à cyril hanouna ou à pierre ménès qui
avait tenu les fameux propos alors c'est
vrai que vous vous y allez vous devez
vous vous balancer grave selon lima
l'arnacoeur je tiens à rappeler
oui je fais pas que balancer dans ce
noble ce que je dis ce n'est via 12
chapitres y en a un qui parle de 2,2 de
mon passage en télévision ça depuis
laurence ferrari a où on était dans une
émission bienveillante et festive a
effectivement tout cela et c'est ce que
je dis c'est que j'ai vécu des choses
qui peuvent me dégoûter aujourd'hui
effectivement de la télévision mais ce
que c'est pas un livre où je balance et
un livre où je dis ma vérité ces votes
érigé eu besoin de la dire parce
qu'effectivement il ya eu un certain
nombre de choses qui se sont accumulés
et qui m'ont conduite à un moment à
prendre la parole est à part et à dire
les choses
voilà donc effectivement cette séquence
on pourrait dire que c'est de la
diffamation comme certains se sont que
les deux cas le producteur de tir
addition qui dit qu'il doit vous
attaquez absolument perdre alors que
vous dites dans le livre voilà mais je
tiens juste à rappeler que la
diffamation c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut pas prouver
voilà quoi et quand on voit cette scène
vous en jugerez comme vous voulez mais
quand moi si je suis à côté de doc
gynéco et chez lui met une tarte déjà
rage j'ai pas besoin d'y mettre une
force de 2 de folie si vous lui mettez
une tarte dans une heure il sera
réveillé mais de toute façon simplement
sur cet épisode vous pouvez simplement
demandé à jules j'ai téléphoné à gilles
le lendemain ce que je raconte et la
façon dont je les perds sujet pas été la
seule à être choqué ce jour là mais j'ai
été la seule à dire attiré ardisson que
je trouvais que ce qu'il avait fait
était inacceptable
si tout ça tout me l'avait dit et
benjamin aussi me l'avait dit et en fait
il m'avait dit que ça dépassait le cas
moi je suis très second degré voyez
jarrige m'amuse et là c'est vrai que
c'était fort et en relisant le livre
d'absa tôt je pense que c'est vrai
finalement je voulais pas y croire mais
je pense que c'est vrai quand on
la scène on voit que ça dépasse le cadre
d'un geste humoristique c'est vraiment
violent avec en arrière-plan
effectivement je pense quelque chose qui
me dépasse c'est comme si dans son
subconscient il voulait vous la mettre à
vous les lots delta connection à je suis
d'accord avec china oui c'est vrai vous
sont les propos de thierry ardisson qui
ont suivi cette séquence sont assez
claires c'est pas à gilles qu'il en
voulait c'était à vous et la vérité
c'est que quand il le fait ce qu'il dit
derrière c'est que voilà c'est il a pris
le dessus et ce que je lui dis à ce
moment là c'est toujours très facile de
s'en prendre aux gens où tu sais qu
toral dessus mais tu n'aurais jamais
fait ça ni à cyril ni à pierre menez
effectivement et je pense qu'il l'aurait
jamais fait l'état déjà essayé on a fait
ici à des personnes où ils savent et art
on en a mis on sait que c'est comme ça
là il mais le gros coup et la main elle
compterait alors moi je me suis dit
après paulo j'en ai pas voulu je me suis
dit pète un peu agacé par la séquence il
veut faire son émission je sais plus est
très cadré bras dans ce qu'il fait il
veut pas trop dépasser la suite sans
fit-il des gestes de violence super
après le redoux et si vous donc il me
fallait pas qu'ils me détestez vous
voyez vous pas donc vous me prenez donc
vos clients je sais pas si on vous aime
ou si vous déteste qui est sûr c'est que
je pense qu'il a eu il fait une certaine
obsession des gens qui à un moment
prennent plus de pouvoirs que lui alors
vous dites également vous parler de la
faire bien sûr zemmour et vous dites
j'ai mis du temps à me remettre de tout
cela même si je pense que je ne m'en
remettrai jamais totalement toute la
journée j'entends parler de cette
histoire en supermarché devant ma fille
certaines personnes m'appellent corinne
croyant faire de l'humour puisqu'on
rappelle qu'il avait dit vous auriez pu
vous appelez corinne aux lieux et audio
capsat ou dans les aéroports dans la rue
dans les taxis tout le monde ment pas
j'aurais payé très cher le fait de venir
faire ce qui était au final simplement
mon boulot et c'est vrai que vous en
souffrez encore après tout mon boulot
c'était de venir m'asseoir sur une
chaîne débattre ce jour là j'ai été
insulté j'ai répondu par le débat j'ai
même pas répondu par l'insulté et tout
ce qui s'en est suivi a été assez
insupportable je suis pas là pour faire
la pleureuse je suis pas une pleureuse
si vous lisez le livre vous comprendrez
que je ne n'ai jamais pleurer sur mon
sort j'ai toujours été une battante
si vous si vous comprenez aussi ce livre
vous comprenez que je me suis construite
sur quelque chose qui fait que je ne
peux pas courber la tête devant
quelqu'un comme thierry ardisson je ne
peux pas l'accepter je le fais devant
mon père et c'est probablement la seule
personne devant laquelle je le fais je
n'ai pas fait devant mes frères je n'ai
pas fait devant qui que ce soit je sujet
j'ai du mal à vivre avec l'injustice
joie une scène qui qui m'attriste
j'interviens et je dis ce que j'ai à
dire mais c'est tout ma construction
tout au long de ma vie qui fait que je
ne reste pas comme ça dans dans le calme
à supporter des choses qui sont
insupportables
donc effectivement quand on me dit
pourquoi tu voyais quand j'ai écrit ce
livre il ya certaines personnes qui
m'ont mis en garde qui m'ont dit tu te
rends compte de ce que tu dis oui je
m'en rends compte
je n'ai pas peur de dire ce que je dis
vous savez la meilleure arme des
personnes comme ça qu'ils se sentent
agressés
quand on dit une vérité les concernant
c'est de dire on va attaquer on va faire
ceci on va faire cela
si c'est un bon moyen de faire taire les
victimes je ne serai pas de ces victimes
là je ne me tairais pas je n'accepterai
pas l'inacceptable
et oui on fait les gens peuvent dire il
ya plus de souffrance ailleurs et chaque
souffrance et compass n'est pas
comparable à une autre mais de vivre
effectivement avec son prénom assimilé à
vie où je ne sais combien de temps
encore au nom de zemmour ce n'est pas un
plaisir quand il dit que j'ai choisi la
polémique vous pensez pas j'ai quand
même une carrière dans dans le business
de soi vous pensez pas que j'aurai
choisi meilleur polémique que celle
d'être assimilée à une personne raciste
aujourd'hui qui tient des propos
inacceptables
je leur ai construit quand même un buzz
assez différent donc tout ce qu'il
explique tout ce qui explique n'est pas
tenable
on ne construit pas un bug sur quelque
chose de si négatif à part si on vous
détruire abîmer son image se prendre
tous les racistes de france ce qui
s'obstine et qui la nuit envoie des
milliers de messages chaque matin au
réveil vous avez le bonheur de les lire
non je jeûne ans